now everything is broken again Olga stop
you as guardian to three kids escaped
for more torn Ukraine but now another
challenge the kids are stuck in Mexico
when I'm doing mistake and it's hurt
only me
it is okay but when by mistake and
suffering kids and they looking at me
and they just ask him don't leave us we
we need to back to Canada August says
after the kids got to Canada she thought
it'd be nice to take them on a vacation
she says her English isn't great so she
asked immigration officers if they could
travel with the documents they have she
says they said yes but the problem they
have a special type of Visa which is
only valid for one entry into Canada
they haven't been able to get approval
to come back and it's now been two
months we've emailed MPS we've started
new applications for new visas but
they've already been approved for visas
once it was just a travel letter issue
so we're hoping we can get them back a
lot sooner than waiting another six
months for a Visa the kids have been
Hotel hopping on a weekly basis unable
to return to Edmonton and it's very hard
to find a space and to move out and
and
please if it's possible just help me to
bring them home The Province says while
the situation is seriously issues a
federal one adding we're hopeful the
federal government can expedite their
visa extension approval process to
assist Ukraine evacuees especially
children we reached out to Canadian
immigration numerous times the office
explained the type of Visa the kids have
but did not comment on whether it would
or could help bring them home safe
Kaiser Global News